yeah hello and welcome to this video bit
of a late start there yeah I left I had
screwed up the video number so let's see
what honey ducks is doing it's going for
a Sicilian defense yeah I don't I don't
really think the open is a good one
I mean it's good yeah but but for me I
need to play some more conservative
chess we should be five check one
attacks by the way is a German there's a
German name example in English it's a
honey badger pretty fierce animal
dangerous some predator the honey badger
so we have a sideline here in the in the
rustle Dima Moscow complex here black
should probably go Bishop g4 getting rid
of the bishop as long as this is still
possible I will play basically whatever
he does if he doesn't go Bishop g4 I
will play aged three and then d4 and
then black has very little to show in
the center all those moves like we
should be seven a6 they don't help all
that much
Bishop G form should be played okay this
is this as possible it's not a
charitable choice but I'm not unhappy
here obviously so it gives me the square
on c3 yeah here the the thing is yeah I
mean d4 is hanging and I think this is
actually better for white I think in my
book I recommended against e5 I
recommended age three to be honest I
think I just play d4 attack too quickly
I mean this is not bad it's something
that I looked at briefly and I wasn't so
sure about this kind of situation when I
was
writing I did not want to allow the
noise to come to d4 but it's not so
terrible or anything yeah how to do that
probably Bishop III is correct allowing
him to take yeah I'm not so happy with
this development it's it's kind of an
untidy position what I don't like so
much
I'm tidy I mean well I'm probably that's
a somewhat weird way to phrase it but
it's kind of how I view it it doesn't
look very doesn't look so organized if
there is a double pawn f3 with the King
on g1 don't really don't really like it
so much
oh it allows me to take on d4 so
surprised you know that I'm happily
taking this opportunity
I could have won the pawn before but
that would have come with a price tag
the double pawn again and now I'm just
getting it for free almost for free he
will get the yes pair of Bishops quite
clearly so it's not completely free porn
okay so he said he basically says that
the opposite colored bishops will help
him that that's probably true Bishop on
f6 is a strong piece or will be a strong
piece and so on what to do here yeah the
bishop will come to f6 and then probably
quickly Knight see half things like that
so I'm looking at the c5 square Bishop
f6 Queen D 295 something like this I go
back 95 f e5 that's an idea rook is fine
on c1 anyway so let's do it it's taking
a long time here
don't know queen a5 something like that
no maybe I was thinking isn't he five
good if five looks like a good move I
mean he can go to e7 but that's that's
not what you want and now before 97 ye
6o there anyway is six of course oh it
takes it I thought Bishop f6 maybe but
okay now um yeah point politics politics
and the bishop should go to d5 if I get
this if I get this opportunity I have to
take it
Bishop wasn't good on f1
and this is a fantastic square really
now if I take it yeah
and go here he cannot play rook d7 G to
e7 that's a self in 94 know that he can
take but I still don't believe this move
you threatening nightie to though that
is it's important
he threatens unlikely true so how do we
do that that must be him here I think I
should have a win a really clean win
don't see it I would like to go 94
that's really really a good good thing
hmm okay let's just do this
okay so he allows me to take here right
queen bee five instead of thing no just
prevent him from activating the only
thing I need to do is make sure that I'm
not blundering a background mate that's
the thing just going I have got I could
everything protected every single thing
that I have is protected so 9h
[Music]
no move yeah yeah I think maybe he had a
little bit of compensation at the very
beginning that I don't know I'm here in
my book I recommended age three I'm I
remember Anna Bishop is 74 that was the
main line this is not bad though it's
just a little bit as I mentioned it's a
little bit untidy D 594 Bishop III I
think black should definitely take now
[Music]
this problem name I think this is
probably slightly better for white not
sure the engine wants to go to D to 2 T
3 yeah he says I thought it got more of
that point sacrifice yeah
[Music]
yeah I don't think it was enough relief
and you can think about this one but
here you have this constant worry that
things happen here maybe this is not
really a problem because I get F for n
like this is man maybe this one I can
even do this I think I think my move is
simple um just just do this and this is
basically doing them it will it will
fall and interesting I think maybe here
when you look at this 95 has to be
avoided you know and then he says he he
saw it but forgot about the tenets
that's very typical happening so I think
this is probably right you have to what
you do here's blacks you have to hope
that the rooks scared of and the heavy
pieces get off the board and then it's
not too bad some something like this a 5
and then then you're kind of still
playing it's not really great but it's
it's probably what you have to do I will
probably play an OB 3 some something
like that and you have to hope that you
get some some opposite colored bishops
anything that you can draw after after
e5 I think black is basically lost that
is absolutely impossible to hold the
bishop comes here yeah I wonder if I
have something better here but King h1
is a strong move I also considered King
f1 and Roxy to so one of those moves
must be right here I didn't like somehow
that there might be checked somewhere
but there's none Roxy to also looked
decent but King edge one is one of the
stronger more so and here yeah it's just
it's just over
yeah that that whole that whole line is
is think I'm not a real huge fan there I
think blab best is this one and after
after this G six or six and I think
white is just very slightly better okay
guys thanks for watching